- Good morning, believe nation.
Today's message is execute your dream.
Over to you, Eddie Murphy.
(rooster crows)
(hip hop music)
- I knew I wanted to be in show business,
and I just happened to luck
out and things happened.
I think you know, you know
what you're supposed to do.
Deep down inside, I think everybody does,
and a lot of people just
don't go after it, you know?
Like, most people start out, they say,
I want to be a this, but
I'm going to get that
to make sure I have
something to fall back on.
And what you're doing is
you're setting yourself up
for failure 'cause you're going,
there's a possibility that
I'm going to fall back.
And when you put that out
there, then you fall back,
but if you just say, hey,
this is what I want to do
and you go do it, you
usually get your stuff
the way you want it, man.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
The question of the day today is
what is preventing you from
executing your true big dream?
What's holding you back?
Leave it in the comments below,
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Lee Geng Yu.
Thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
It really, really,
really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is, much love.
And I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot
of Entspresso.
(hip hop music)
What's up, believe nation?
If you want a little more motivation
on executing your dream, stay
tuned for some bonus clips.
- My assistant's got a
great thing now in this.
Once in every four months,
somebody sends an email
saying, "I've got a huge startup
"that I want you to invest in,
"but you've got to sign this NDA," right?
Which literally every time
gets an email back that says,
"Fuck you," right?
And the reason is, I'm a
humongous believer that ideas
are shit and that
execution's the game, right?
We've all got ideas.
Everybody's got ideas.
Do you know how many (bleep)
ideas we all have here?
We can probably sit here
for the next two hours,
draw them all out, record
them, and predict the next 78
great startups over the next nine years.
And?
So I think the thing that is another theme
in entrepreneurship is
there is way too much fodder
brought to the idea.
Uber was Magic Cab three years earlier.
Uber is not an idea, Uber
existed, it was called Magic Cab.
But the guys that executed
it sucked, so they lost.
So I think, you know, if there's
any level of romance left
in this room about your idea,
I'd like to suffocate it
because I think the actual situation
is what you actually do with it.
- The way of the entrepreneur
is actually about looking at
the world and finding problems.
It's actually, some people
think that's a negative mindset,
but actually I find it is
like, a curious mindset.
'Cause you're out there
looking for problems,
looking for things that aren't the way
they should be or could be.
Okay, you got a good idea.
Look, everybody's got
a good idea, you know?
Okay, everybody has an idea,
not everybody has a good idea,
but lots of people have good ideas.
Look, Uber's a good idea.
You push a button and get a ride.
I don't know if we were the first person
to ever think of that idea,
but we were the first person to do it.
And so you've got to just go do it then.
You got to just get
out there and go do it.
So it's easy to have the
idea, or straightforward,
but then you've got to have enough guts
to go out there and try.
And that's the way of the entrepreneur.
- I think you famously said,
"Strategy is 5% of the
answer and execution is 95%."
So what does that mean, and
what did you do differently?
- Yeah, 5% of the challenge is
strategy, 95% the execution,
this I said it as CEO as Nissan
and I said it also as CEO
of Renault, and I said it
as Deputy CEO of Renault.
When I said it the first
time, it was maybe in France,
and that was to the top
management of Renault in France
because there was a
tendency in the company
to spend too much time on strategy
and leave the execution for other people.
And this is where I said,
"Yeah, strategy is fine,
it's very important, but it's only 5%."
If you don't go to execution after this,
the delivery and the
performance of the company
is going to be very weak.
I really, really believe it.
Now, it doesn't mean
strategy's not important,
but when you establish north,
and you know exactly where
north is for the company,
you've done something very important
because you're giving the direction.
But if you don't start moving north,
if you don't start mapping
and establishing milestones,
you're never going to be getting there.
You're never going to be getting there.
- Execute.
And you need to execute
as fast as possible.
Because the thing at the end of the day is
whether you feel you
have competitors or not,
sooner or later you're
going to have someone
and if you can't move fast enough,
someone's going to beat you to the punch.
So make sure whatever you're
doing, you get something out
within a month or two.
If it takes you longer than that,
you're taking way too long.
I created this company called Serph
and it was in Rockwell,
Texas, right by Dallas.
And I had this brilliant idea.
Have any of you guys
heard of the Media Temple
Grid server solution?
That was my idea a year
or two before it came out.
And I spent a million bucks on it
trying to actually do that
idea before Media Temple.
The funny thing is I didn't
have a million bucks,
I actually had to borrow a million bucks,
and I spent it on business
partners who moved really slow
and really weren't the
best at what they did.
Within 12 months we launched nothing.
They also had some of the problems
in my previous slide, right?
Like financial instability,
and they had a family
and kids of I think like six.
So I even bought 'em a
home in Rockwell, Texas
that cost 200 and something thousand.
Why did I buy it instead of renting it?
I have no clue, I was stupid and young.
But nonetheless, I lost
over a million bucks on that
of borrowed money.
Not investor money, but borrowed money
that I had to pay back.
And it failed miserably because
we never launched anything.
If you can't launch something,
somebody like Media Temple's
going to beat you to the punch,
get a ton of customers,
and make a lot of money.
So lessons I learned from that?
Set deadlines.
No matter what, you have to set deadlines.
People have to be held accountable
to them as well, right?
You can't just set a deadline,
it passes, nothing happens.
Someone better be meeting 'em.
If not, you know, something has to change.
You also need to make sure they're small.
If the deadlines, like
milestones, goals, are too big
for those deadlines, they're
not going to get met.
So make 'em really small and tangible,
that way you can see it
really well in advance
if they're actually
going to be met or not.
And last but not least,
don't worry about perfection.
A lot of people are like,
"dude, I'm going to create
the most perfect version of,"
you know, whatever it may be.
"That has a lot of problems,
mine's going to be perfect."
Perfection is overrated,
nothing's ever perfect.
You're going to continue to have
to iterate, so forth, so on.
It's never going to be perfect,
there's always going to be issues,
just get it out there and
start trying to make money.
- Well the last and the
most valuable lesson
as an entrepreneur I learned,
was about the value of execution.
Way too many people, way too
many people spend too much time
thinking about the vision.
We are taught that you have
to build a better mousetrap.
Every venture capitalist will tell you
that to be a successful entrepreneur,
you need to break through innovation.
Well you have to assume, none
of us, or at least most of us,
are not the smartest people in the world.
There are lots and lots of
great, great inventors out there.
How are we going to be the person
who's going to always
build a better mousetrap?
Well, to be successful, you don't have to
build a better mousetrap.
You just have to build
a different mousetrap.
And as long as you are executing well,
the business always comes
down to block and tackle.
It's not about the great vision,
it's always about the great execution.
And you can always succeed
by out-executing your competitors,
not necessarily having the best
product in the marketplace.
And I think that Microsoft
is a great example.
Where they took a same product
that other people may have had,
but they executed it substantially better
and today are the market
leader in the industry.